let's talk about pharmacies you know
those places that let you arm a
robot or as some people insist on
calling that getting your blood pressure
taken when you picture a pharmacy in
your mind you probably imagine a place
that your doctor calls in a prescription
and someone counts out pills that were
manufactured somewhere else but that is
actually a relatively new phenomenon a
lot of pharmacies used to make
medication on sites as this old film
shows a doctor's prescription may seem
mysterious to the average layman but
it's all very simple to the pharmacist
it is his responsibility to make sure
that each prescription is filled exactly
as the doctor has ordered an error in
the compounding of a prescription could
be injurious or even fatal to the
patient yes any error could be fatal
which is why we only hire nearsighted
men to eyeball ratios out of a series of
identical bottles and if that doesn't
work do feel free to die happy nineteen
forties to water all and well that is
obviously no longer how it works in your
local CVS there are places that do still
make their drugs from scratch on site
they are called compounding pharmacies
and they exist for a very good reason
compounding pharmacies make medicine for
people whose needs cannot be met by an
fda-approved product let's say you're
allergic to a specific ingredient in a
pill your doctor can write a
prescription tailored to your specific
needs and a compounding pharmacy will
mix it that's right compounding
pharmacies basically make bespoke
medication I'd say designer drugs if
that phrase hadn't already been taken by
egregiously Dutch dealers selling pills
to suburban kids dishes to good
trust me it's it's going to send you to
out this fish it's for your dance
parties seventy five hundred compounding
pharmacies all over this country and
they can fill highly specific
prescriptions for all sorts of reasons
maybe you're having trouble swallowing
pills they can make the same drug in
liquid form maybe you need a drug in a
lower concentration and what's
commercially available they can do that
for you so they do very important work
and it is not just humans that benefit
there are no manufactured medications
maybe for birds so you need to go to
your compounding pharmacist so they can
make the right volume because it could
be large medium or small each one might
like a different flavor or require a
different volume
she likes pina colada flavor that's it
really a tropical bird whose favorite
flavor is Pina Colada look I'm just
gonna say it that parrot is basic your
basic your a basic bird so at this point
so far so good but as you probably guess
from the very fact that we're talking
about this three in the first place
there are some huge problems here
because compounding pharmacies are
subject to much less oversight than
large drug manufacturers if you get a
drug that was mass-produced in a factory
both the drug and the factory are under
a lot of scrutiny but if you get one
from a compounding pharmacy it is very
different as a former head of the FDA
will tell you compounded drugs are not
FDA approved as commissioner of the FDA
then you can't tell us sitting here now
that every drug being used in the United
States is safe and effective no I really
cannot holy that's kind of starting
to hear isn't it and look at one level
it does make sense that if compounding
pharmacies are making bespoke medication
the FDA doesn't treat them like they're
a giant manufacturer you know you
wouldn't subject Mikey's Lemonade Stand
to the same regulations coca-cola has to
obey for mass producing Minute Maid
because that would be overkill and
besides even if Mikey did pee a little
bit in his lemonade which let's face it
he definitely did
the damage is inherently limited but as
you will see oversight is so lacks that
compounding pharmacies have become the
Wild West of the drug industry resulting
in fraud and in the worst cases many
many people dying and you may not even
know that you're taking a compounded
drug because they can be used in clinics
or hospitals without your or your
doctor's knowledge so tonight let's take
a look at this industry let's start with
the fraud a few years back TRICARE the
military's health insurance program
noticed a big increase in being built
for veterans specially compounded scar
and pain creams but there was a problem
as the man who oversaw the program
admitted are these creams a viable
alternative for treating the pain of
wounded warriors they don't appear to be
we don't have any evidence that supports
that and he was right about that those
creams were total one study
found that they didn't work any better
than treatments that contained no
medicine at all and it's shocking that
that was allowed and it is why I'm so
excited to announce my amazing new pain
cream
Johnny gel it's it's great for relieving
tenderness in your back neck and joint
and yes it is just mayonnaise ask your
doctor if Johnny gel is right for you
now what happened was a number of
compounding pharmacies realized that
there was a loophole where they could
build TRICARE for the cost of each
individual ingredient in their creams so
they simply added as many expensive
ingredients as they could and by the
time the military realized what was
happening the costs have gotten
ridiculous it's just been an
astronomical explosion of the charges in
a relatively short period of time we're
on track this year to spend over two
billion dollars unless we get our hands
around this two billion two billion
dollars when we talk about overspending
in the military I don't think anyone
would have guessed a not insignificant
chunk of that has gone to lotion
and unfortunately even when there isn't
fraud it is not rare for compounded
medication to be ineffective when the
FDA tests drugs from commercial
manufacturers the failure rate is
typically below two percent but when
they run tests on compounded drugs
around 33 percent of the drugs failed
that's one in three
put that in perspective contact the
drugs have about the same failure rate
as the Jonas Brothers we all know we all
know which one I'm talking about and it
is not you Kevin you are doing great
come on guys he's been through enough
you're doing really great Kevin you're
actually my favorite but a drug simply
not working is by no means the worst
case scenario here because while again
you would not expect the FDA to be
testing every small batch drug made you
would at least hope that someone was
making sure the places they were made
were clean the conditions can be
appalling as multiple investigations
have found over the years with some
particularly revolting examples in one
Miami pharmacy a compounded drug for
lung disease was found in the same
refrigerator as the employees lunch at
another pharmacy compounded drugs were
stored in the employees bathroom it
sickened me and really did bothered me a
lot yeah it should have second you
because you should not store an open box
of loose pills next to a toilet
I've never been to pharmacy school but
I'm pretty sure lesson one is don't put
the pills where you poop so how could
that happen well in the absence of FDA
oversight state pharmacy boards are
supposed to send inspectors to make sure
conditions are sanitary but in many
states there is an extreme shortage of
them as of 2016 Hawaii had only one
inspector Kansas had two and Illinois
had just three despite the fact it has
nearly 2700 pharmacies meaning each
inspector would have been tasked with
900 locations to keep an eye on and the
only way that it's possible if the
inspectors are just texting each
pharmacy you're good and this lack of
oversight can be especially dangerous if
a lab is producing sterile drugs that
are injected into the body a few years
back one compounding pharmacy made
national headlines after it was found to
be the source of a massive meningitis
outbreak the Food and Drug
Administration is telling doctors don't
use any products from the New England
compounding
Center you know when they went in there
they actually found fungus in a vial
that you could see with naked eye they
saw some guck for want of a better word
in it they put it under a microscope and
it was a fungus that is disgusting
the only worse thing to find in a vial
of medicine than visible guck would be a
visible duck because putting aside the
issue of Hygiene how did you miss this
how did you not hear the quacking your
oversights a mess and while it
would have been comfortably bad enough
if that pharmacy any CC was just making
drugs for individual patients it was
actually producing medication in bulk
the thing remember it was absolutely not
supposed to do compounding pharmacies
are supposed to do small batches based
on individual prescriptions for any cc
skirted those rules to make more money
shipping their medical education to 23
different states eventually killing more
than a hundred people and it's a little
weird that you don't remember that story
right well though to be fair it was 2012
and we were all distracted trying to
find Kony at the time where's Cody did
we get him did we get Cody does anyone
remember it seems so important at the
time I bet we got him we wouldn't have
just given up would we look while
regulations required them to have an
individual prescription for each patient
they managed to get around that by
simply faking patient names and not even
seeming to try that hard
investigators also allege that employees
falsified prescriptions with fake names
like big baby Jesus Roy Rogers Wonder
Woman and Budweiser
but why it's like they were trying to
get caught and it didn't even stop there
they also fill prescriptions with names
and this is this is real like Jimmy
Kimmel David Schwimmer Michael Bolton
Jack Bauer Sarah Marshall RuPaul and
Method Man and that is such a gloriously
random group of people most people would
see no connection between them unless
you are me and you have some very
specific very bold theories about who
killed JFK I've clearly cracked it none
of you leave the country I think there
may have been a second Schwimmer but
this this scheme though was incredibly
lucrative in fact the president of any
Cece Barry Cadden made over 60 million
dollars in the three years leading up to
the outbreak and he seemed to know what
he was doing was wrong
because he was once asked at a filmed
employee training session about keeping
records of patient names and
prescriptions and his answer was
comically suspicious there's no wonder
one patient names for the Barbara blocks
that's something for another time yeah
what sign that's we can talk about that
those that's actually one of the more
difficult things we do let's just talk
about the products now okay well we're
being recorded okay if you are being
recorded saying you don't want to say
something while being recorded you've
probably already said too much
all right so this is where we keep the
guns or the ski masks and the big bags
of money with dollar signs on them where
does that money come from well I
probably shouldn't talk about that while
we've been recorded
the defining hallmark of any CC was just
how clearly everyone knew that they were
breaking the law at one point the
company's national sales director even
sent out an email with the unassuming
subject line huge importance which reads
in part all names must resemble real
names no obviously fake names and I know
I don't have to say this but also never
put anything in writing which is the
criminal thing to put in writing now
thankfully Cadden eventually went to
prison and Congress passed a law
toughening up enforcement of regulations
among compounding pharmacies which is
great in theory the problem is they
wrote in some massive loopholes for
instance the law required any pharmacy
that wanted to mass-produce drugs you
know the way that any CC did to register
as something called an outsourcing
facility and submit to much stricter
inspections but it made doing so
completely voluntary and and if you need
if you need everyone to obey a rule it
just can't be voluntary it's like stop
signs say stop and not shrug emoji and
so perhaps unsurprisingly only
seventy-seven facilities are currently
registered that's just 1% of compounding
pharmacies and because the FDA had no
system to catch violators many
pharmacies just carried on exactly as
they were with something pretty bold
about it how bold just watch this the
FDA's inspection of downing labs in July
found sterility failures in 19 lots of
drug products ashley downing is the
co-owner of downing labs they asked you
to recall your sterile products that's
correct
and you decided what no just no that's
it she responded to a request for a drug
recall the way most of us responded to
seeing the trailer for the movie cats no
I refuse to acknowledge that this is
happening
no no no suppose she claimed the FDA had
no jurisdiction over her and that she
followed all state requirements but the
FDA disagreed and while they eventually
did manage to force her to comply that
didn't happen until almost a full year
after that interview and when oversight
is this week compounding pharmacies can
hurt large numbers of people for a long
time just just look at what happened
recently in Texas with a company called
Guardian pharmacy services this is it
here that they apparently mass-produced
medicine which was injected into
people's eyes and which turned out to
contain formaldehyde and acetone two
things pretty high up the list of things
to keep away from your eyes right above
jalapeno peppers and just below the
trailer for cats no I said no guardian
didn't opt in for FDA oversight so it
was regulated at the state level but not
it seems very well because nearly 70
people who were injected with their
drugs are now partially or completely
blind and yet it took six months from
the first injections for state
regulators to even be notified that
there was a problem which is something
understandably frustrating for the
people who ended up losing their sight
by the time Susie Pope went in for
cataract surgery at a Dallas eye clinic
dozens of patients had gone before her
how could 68 people be involved before
they pull that off the shelf many of
them have the same question we know this
real quick hell when lettuce is bad we
report it off the shelf every week yeah
and of course he's right it's frankly
not unreasonable to want a world where
you can feel confident that's something
that's about to be injected into your
eyeball is at least as safe as lettuce
because I'll tell you what is a safe as
lettuce and that is Johnny gel I have to
say Johnny gel may not be as safe as
lettuce and yet incredibly
not only do be Texas state pharmacy
boards not shut down Guardian they
haven't shut down a single compounding
pharmacy in at least five years now you
should know they did put Guardians
license on probation but the man behind
it simply shut it down and opened up a
pharmacy called Medical Park Pharmacy at
the exact same location so they door
simply changed from this to this and it
is hard to notice any meaningful
differences there
even if you won't recently blinded by
some tainted own medication and look
again compounded pharmacists play an
important role but that is all the more
reason why they should be properly
regulated so at the very least we need
more inspectors at the state level the
outsourcing facilities designation
should not be voluntary and compounders
should have to alert regulators whenever
they up and until then bad
facilities could probably really benefit
from a message from some of the very
real names that they've thrown around in
their nonsense prescriptions hey I'm
David Schwimmer
I'm Method Man I am obviously RuPaul I'm
Jimmy Kimmel America's favorite
late-night host by far Michael Bolton
and we'd like to say a few words to
compounding pharmacies please don't use
our names in your prescriptions
we're not just random words to be thrown
around so you can evade the law we're
real people well some of us are like me
Jack Bauer and me Sarah Marshall who do
not tell me you forgot Sarah Marshall oh
you're the one who broke up with Jason
Segel's dick sure did the point is we're
mad real mad because our names don't
belong on your fraudulent spinal
medication mine belongs on a platinum
album mine belongs on the list of
America's top pretend paleontologists
and mine belongs on the Emmy for
Outstanding variety talk series at
somebody else
again so stop using our names to turn
your compounding pharmacy into an
unregulated drug manufacturer and while
we're at it don't even think about
trying to sell us any of that $15,000
game cream we don't want to be involved
in your lotion scam honey I'm not
getting mixed up in your ointment scheme
good boy and if you're an outsourcing
facility let yourself be regulated like
one because if you don't I will tie you
up in a dark basement in a black site in
southern Turkmenistan and I will inflict
a level of pain on you you could not
imagine in your darkest most terrifying
nightmares Jesus yes but even more
importantly we need to make sure that
compounded drugs are coming from labs
that fully comply with safety guidelines
because keep in mind lots of people need
compounded drugs and it's not just
people my bird needs them too yeah but
what Michael Bolton has a parrot of
course I do
I love parrots to people not realize
that how am I supposed to live without
you is about a lady parrot I love that
part
and she reckoned she did leave them for
me you Michael Bolton yeah you
Michael Bolton you and finally
until you're better regulated you should
stick to what you were designed to do
making pina coladas for birds I miss you
what the
you